in this lesson we're going to go over
the degree of unsaturation which is also
called the index of hydrogen deficiency
what this is going to tell us is the
number of rings or double bonds in our
compound now knowing the number of rings
in double bonds is going to help us out
a lot when we try to draw Lewis
structures also when we look at NMR
spectroscopy and we're given a formula
but we don't know what the compound is
it's great to get a quick idea of how
many double bonds and rings might be in
your structure so if the degree of
unsaturation tells us the number of
rings and double bonds what we need to
know is how many hydrogen atoms we
should expect in the saturated compound
now the saturated compound will have no
rings no double bonds and it's going to
be saturated with hydrogen's it's going
to have the most hydrogen atoms that it
can we can use this equation to n + 2 to
figure out the number of hydrogen atoms
in the saturated compound where n is the
number of carbon atoms in the formula
let's do a quick example to get started
propane has three carbon atoms so let's
use our equation to figure out the
number of hydrogen atoms it should have
plugging the number 3 into our equation
we can see that the saturated compound
should have eight hydrogen atoms now
let's look at propane structurally to
see why this works okay so here I've
drawn out three carbons bonded together
how propane will be now what we need to
do is add on the hydrogen atoms we know
that every carbon atom needs to have
four bonds so let's draw sticks on the
end to show that
so our end carbon will need three bonds
to have its four bonds the middle carbon
is already bonded in two directions so
we just have to add two extra bonds on
there
and our other terminal carbon needs
three bonds
okay so filling in for bonds for every
carbon atom gives us one two three four
five six seven eight hydrogen atoms so
that's why our equation works now
imagine we bonded each of these end
carbon atoms into a ring well when
they're bonded they'll have an extra
bond already in order to avoid making
five bonds to carbon we have to lose one
of the hydrogen atoms from each carbon
so the number of H atoms in the formula
containing a ring is two less than the
saturated compound
okay now imagine adding a double bond
here we need to get rid of one H atom on
each carbon to add the double bond so we
can see when we introduce a ring or a
double bond into our compound it's going
to decrease the number of hydrogen atoms
in our formula by two now let's write up
an equation for the index of hydrogen
deficiency to calculate our index of
hydrogen deficiency we're going to first
look at this formula we'll calculate the
number of hydrogen atoms in our
saturated formula and then we'll
subtract the number of hydrogen atoms in
our given formula now remember we're
losing two hydrogen's for each double
bond and each ring so if we simply
divide this by two this will give us the
exact number of double bonds or rings in
our compound everything's so much
clearer with an example let's take a
look at a couple okay let's figure out
the index of hydrogen deficiency for
c3h6 up here we already calculated that
we should have eight hydrogen atoms in
the formula but we have six let's set up
our ihd equation so eight hydrogen atoms
for the saturated compound minus the six
in our given formula divided by two is
one
so now we know we have one double bond
or one ring in our formula now we can
make a hypothesis about our structure
let's first start by introducing a ring
okay in our ring structure each carbon
starts off by having two bonds so we
need to add two more bonds onto each
carbon to get the four bonds that carbon
likes to have one neutral now if we add
on our H atoms we can see we have two
four six hydrogen atoms and that agrees
with our formula another possibility for
our structure is one that has one double
bond let's see what that'll look like
okay here's our skeleton of carbon atoms
this end one already has two bonds
coming from the double bond so we need
to put two H atoms on this central
carbon we'll need one additional bond
and finally this terminal carbon has
only one bond and needs three
substituents
adding in our H atoms we can see that we
again have six so this structure
cyclopropane and this structure propene
both are possibilities for c3h6 formula
in our next example let's explore
unsaturation in the formula C 3 H 4
we're still using C 3 here so we know
that our saturated structure should have
8 hydrogen atoms here's our equation to
compare our saturated structure with the
formula we're given and this equation
gives us a degree of unsaturation of 2
okay so what are our possibilities well
we could have one ring and one double
bond in it let's see what that looks
like okay so our top carbon needs two
substituents because it's bonded in two
directions already now these two carbon
atoms have a double bond and a single
bond so they already have three bonds to
them they each need one additional
substituent adding on our hydrogen's we
can see we have the correct number of H
atoms and knowing the degree of
unsaturation helped us to draw this very
quickly okay there's a couple other
possibilities for this structure one
possibility is that we have two double
bonds the only way to draw that is to
connect each of the carbon atoms with a
double bond to the next one our central
carbon already has four bonds and each
terminal carbon needs two extra bonds
since it's double bonded to the carbon
beside it when we add in our H atoms we
see that there are four and we see that
this structure works for our C 3 H 4
formula
now earlier we said the index of
hydrogen deficiency gives us the number
of rings or double bonds in a compound
but if we have a degree of unsaturation
of two we might also have a triple bond
we can add our triple bond here or here
because each of those will give us
equivalent structures okay so now let's
inspect our carbon atoms the central one
already has four bonds this terminus
needs one additional bond because
it has one two three bonds from the
triple bond
and on this side this carbon only has
one bond so we have to add three adding
on our hydrogen atoms again gives us the
four from our formula so a degree of
unsaturation of two can either mean one
ring with one double bond two double
bonds in our structure to give us this a
lien or we can get an alkyne because two
double bonds come together to make a
triple bond in this lesson we looked at
how to calculate the number of hydrogen
atoms on a saturated hydrocarbon using
the number of carbon atoms in the
structure we then looked at how to
compare the actual number of hydrogen
atoms in a given structure to determine
the ihd the index of hydrogen deficiency
tells us the number of double bonds or
rings in a compound an index of hydrogen
deficiency of two can mean one ring in
one double bond two double bonds or a
triple bond KP here if you learn
something give me a thumbs up on the way
out and for more chemistry subscribe to
my channel